ви хочете вкрасти когось задовольнити
щоб цей хтось із його групою голосував
за весь непотріб беспредел в регламенті
кого ви боїтеся ви боїтеся Правди друзі
Всіх вітаю це Верховна Рада перше
пленарне засідання цього непростого
24-го року вже немає сумніву що третій
рік війни буде складнішим за попередні
два і це Гірка правда життя якою треба
навчитися розмовляти з власним народом і
вона
далека від солодкої брехні телемарафона
почалося перше пленарне засідання 24го
року зі скандалу знов прилаштовують
родичів близьких людей на ті місця які
мають контролювати щоб не вкрали бо ви
хочете вкрасти слуги протягли на посаду
голови рахункової палати Ольгу піщанську
це подруга родини зеленських і їх
сусідка по парадному в Кривому Розі
нагадаю всі посли Великої сімки
звернулись до парламенту сказали не
призначайте нових членів рахункової
палати не призначайте голову рахункової
палати до реформи цього органу чому
слугам життєво необхідно потрібно було
протягти туди на 200% свою людину тому
що саме рахункова палата вона моніторить
як витрачаються державні кошти і як
будуть витрачатися Кошти які дають
Україні наші міжнародні партнери І що
робите ви наплювали витерли ноги
призначаємо нам плювати А завтра скажуть
як же так де підтримка чого нам гроші не
дають да тому що ми живемо за їхній
рахунок і вони говорять Ми хочемо бачити
як рахункова палата контролює що ви не
вкрадете це все Зеленський обіцяв Вже
нам закінчити епоху кумавства але бачимо
що тепер все судівство Да там там сусіди
дружніми рядами або там друзі по
кварталу займають Ключові посади
розумієте чому вас не призначають Ну
тому що ви не сусіди президента не друзі
не родичі Ваша сестра не є власницею
фірми на яка оформлена Віла родини
зеленських Ну не не пощастило вам
розумієте а пані піщанській пощастило Ну
і навіть самім слугам було соромно
голосувати за таке відверте абсолютно
непрофесійне кадрове рішення іті ки 170
слуг дали на голоси але 254 народних
депутати підтримали цю пані піщанську і
це були в першу чергу 170 слуг плюс опзж
їх партнери стефанчук з ними не тільки
пам'ятники відкриває а там знаєте отакі
от Дружба і контакт за
252 рішення прийнято Дякую Шановні
колеги Вітаємо з призначенням насправді
найважливішим рішенням і голосуванням
першого пленарного дня став законопроект
про медицину фронтову цей законопроект
каже якщо ми як країна задекларували що
ми рухаємося в НАТО То цей рух в НАТО
має передбачати в тому числі наближення
наших стандартів надання медичної
допомоги українським військовим в сфері
військової медицини коли парамедики на
полі боя можуть врятувати
військовослужбовця тільки за однієї
умови якщо поряд якісний спеціальний
медичний рюкзак спеціально медична
аптечка і якісні турнікети і це
безумство що тільки на другому році
повномасштабного вторгнення ми підходимо
до необхідності унормувати ці протоколи
клінічні і ці підходи до стандартів НАТО
Я дуже щаслива разом з колежанками бути
співавтором цього важливого
законопроекту щоразу відвідуючи лінію
зіткнення ми буваємо в фронтових в цих
військових госпіталях знаємо
проблематику з неякісними турнікетами ми
неодноразово піднімали це і на нарадах з
міністерством оборони тому що оці кілька
хвилин які є в парамедиків на лінії
фронту витягти військовослужбовця і
надати першу допомогу або рятують життя
або можуть стати фатальними І от в цьому
контексті друзі для нас важливо сьогодні
прийняти цей законопроект не лише за
основу а в цілому Там немає що змінювати
поправками він написаний абсолютно чітко
стандарти НАТО швид кість надання першої
послуги допомогти лікарю врятувати
військовослужбовця на полі бою і нести
відповідальність за тим хто поставляє
неякісні аптечки в умовах коли скільки
говорять про корупцію і зловживання в
міністерстві оборони за попереднього там
керівництва одне питання Так а хто
понесе відповідальність за це де
відповідальність за розкрадені мільярди
і до речі саме рахункова палата в своєму
звіті розкрила так само ці системні
зловжива
Мабуть тому і змінюють сьогодні склад
рахункової палати і ставлять туди своїх
виконавців які ніколи нічого більше не
будуть помічати з корупцією Ну і
справжнім тестом на суб'єктність
Верховної Ради і голови парламенту Стала
історія з незмінною да такою необхідною
безцінною для офісу президента слугою
офісу Маріаною безуглою нагадаю що в
Верховній Раді зареєстровано кілька
постанов про її відкликання з комітету
нацбезпеки але навіть в самому комітеті
де більшість складають слуги вона так
всіх дістала що комітет зареєстрував
постанову про її відкликання з посади
перш заступниці голови комітету Я прошу
вас поставити на голосування питання яке
регламентний комітет рекомендував
Верховній Раді розглянути позачергово це
постанова номер
10391 щодо відкликання пані безуглої з
посади українське суспільство вимагає
щоб Верховна Рада визначилася з цього
питання Дякую я просто хочу нагадати що
ви представляєте фракцію слуга народу
народні депутати які входять в будь-яку
фракцію вони там не рабі наша фракція
тричі навіть чотири рази піднімала
питання негайного розгляду цієї
постанови вимагаємо від голови Верховної
Ради поставити зараз на пленарне
засідання постанову про відкликання пані
безуглої вимагаємо відразу після цього
голосування поставити в порядок денний
постанову про відкликання пані безуглої
абсолютно безвідповідальної людини яка
щодня дискредитує збройні сили України
яка принижувала наших загиблих партійців
колеги з голосу з батьківщини і навіть
самі слуги народу і група розумкова так
само вимагали від спікера ну припинити
це блюзнірства і прошу Так само
поставити на голосування Постанову щодо
відкликання пані безуглою з посади
заступника голови комітета ви я прошу
поставити на голосування пропозицію
шановного народного депутати крівашеєва
і розглянути це питання фракція
батьківщини абсолютно повністю в повній
мірі
підтримує голосування за постановою
власне тут задача голови Верховної Ради
просто винести його в порядок денний але
для голови Верховної Ради і для голови
президентської фракції безугла настільки
безцінна що навіть ціною власного
авторитету авторитету парламенту от вони
її вчора грудьми спинами лубами захищали
і сьогодні це питання не піднімалося на
фракції на погоджувальній раді і
інформую вас що голова Верховної Ради
запізнився на погоджувальну раду можливо
він був з опзж на пам'ятниках в цей час
і не чув що там піднімалося питання
депутатам прийшлося навіть блокувати
трибуну аби вимагати цього кадрового
рішення закон
законн закон закон закон Тим більше що
вчора парламент знайшов можливість для
ін
кадрових рішень наприклад
а журналістку 1+1 олігархічного каналу
25% якого належить родині медведчуків
пані василевську смаглюк призначили
заступницю голови фінансового комітету
ну 1 +1 Ти не один знаєте що таке Love
Is Love is - це коли друг в СІЗО
замінити його на посаді заступника
голови комітету фінансового оце Справжня
дружба друзі Ви знаєте поки игор
валерович сизо Коломойский але я бачу
что дело його живёт його питомц
продовжують посідати провідні місця А як
же без них тому що попередній заступник
цього комітету пан дубінський зараз
знаходиться в СІЗО Ну і звичайно жоден
парламентський день не обходиться без
законопроектів імені гетманцева Є
пропозиція перейти від цих політичних
баталій до дійсно важливих питань які
необхідні для нашої Перемоги сували
проєкти які надають там певні пільги і
преференції для списання там боргів на
за електроенергію на окупованих
територіях тут зараз знову протягується
лобістський проект закону слухайте Куди
ви Заходите нам гроші потрібні чи ви
будете зараз роздавати такі лобійстські
лобістські пільги для того щоби когось
задовольнити щоб цей хтось із його
групою голосував за весь непотріб який
сьогодні тут розглядається дуже сумно що
парламент замість того аби займатися
життєважливими для країни питаннями
підтримки збройних сил України захисту
економіки ну бовсається в оцій багнюці
якою створили слуги і на жаль маємо
абсолютно безвідповідального сьогодні
голову Верховної Ради який створив
додаткові конфлікти в парламенті
підписавши абсолютно незаконне
розпорядження з перевищенням своїх
службових о ов'язків яким встановив тут
колгосп імені стефанчука і такий нквд де
він буде визначати хто з депутатів має
право там працювати в міжнародних
міжпарламентських делегаціях Хто Ні це
кримінальний злочин
перешкоджання міжпарламентської
дипломатії керівництво парламенту має
скасувати огідні і незаконні
розпорядження про
блокування виїзду депутатів і формування
делегацій постійних міжпарламентських
об'єднань Я вже подала до суду на пана
стефанчука щодо цих незаконних рішень
Мої колеги доєднуються до цих позовів І
от зараз готують ці пакети документів І
будемо реєструвати їх в судах для того
аби захистити парламентаризм тому що
мова там не про прізвища не про наше
ставлення до конкретного стефанчука
Навіщо робити порушення за порушенням
Давайте припинимо
сьогодні реально безпредел в
регламенті що в кулуарах Верховної Ради
як ви бачите порожньо трошечки покажу
вам як зараз от виглядають кулуари
бачите жодного жодного журналіста нікого
тут немає не допускають сьогодні медіа
до Верховної Ради вона продовжує
працювати закрито чому Ну тому що багато
речей слугам і владі потрібно приховати
від народу від суспільства на жаль і це
ненормально керівництво парламенту має
негайно скасувати заборону на трансляції
засідання Верховної Ради заборону на
трансляції засідань погоджувальної ради
і запустити журналістів
фоє кого ви
боїтеся українського народу ні ви
боїтеся Правди тому друзі хочу запевнити
вас щоєвропе Солідарність не просто буде
інформувати про роботу Верховної Ради В
24му році а й зробимо все для того аби
захистити демократію захистити
парламентаризм в коментарях будь ласка
запитуйте про роботу парламенту
коментуйте Які закони для вас є
важливими про що більше б хотіли ви
почути і не забувайте підписуватися
лайкати і коментувати Дякуємо все буде
Україна